okay now when you see or hear the word
optimizing what do you think of or
what's that what's the root word
underneath it I'll optimize and even
more than that I suppose optimal right
ultimately what does optimally it means
best best okay so optimizing is about
going through a series of solutions
right and testing them all out until you
get the very best one okay so it's not
testing multiple solutions until you
arrive at the one where you like this
one is better than all the rest okay
because I've sort of given it a test run
I've tried to anticipate what would
happen if I use this solution and this
is what gives me the best result okay
now when do we use this when do people
use this hmm think about this um number
one it assumes that you know what the
multiple solutions are right and also
that after you test all of them you sort
of got so mum a concrete way to measure
this one is better than that one okay so
a common example of this for everyday
life is when you go to buy shoes okay
how do you buy shoes you think about
this okay let's assume you pick the
style that's not worried about the style
that's very complicated question we're
just trying to picture shoe size okay
how do you pick shoe size ok so number
one okay the multiple solutions are very
well defined right there's size 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 okay but all the numbers are
there right and simply a matter of okay
well you know maybe if you've never worn
shoes before you just where I don't only
wear thongs every or something like that
oh I don't know what it's not so you
just start at one side you put your foot
in it okay my toes can't even get into
this I guess that doesn't work so you go
to the next one and then you go to the
next one bank I think you might get to
when you like I this is pretty good okay
you test the next one and the other
order this is what okay because it went
too big it's too loose okay so you can
you see there you're testing each one
and then you arrive at one yard yes this
is the one
okay this is the best um to give you
another example one that's a little more
complex for example we said I'll we said
shoes shoe size I'll when I cook at
least particular kinds of dishes right I
test out different recipes with an
optimized the approach okay so i don't
know if any of you eat this i'm a bit of
a fan it has a chinese day which I can't
say properly because my country
intermission it would embarrass myself
but I pork belly right you're cooking in
oven right and let me tell you a little
bit about how it works you have to arm
it's sort of like it's it's it's it's
the belly right since the outside so
it's like skin and fat and then there's
meat underneath right so here's the
challenge okay you want really high
temperatures to make the skin nice and
crispy okay but you also want low
temperatures so that it doesn't like for
dryer okay now um how did I work out
because you actually have to transition
from one to the other how'd that work
out yeah no seriously right what
temperature do i start at whatever
jago-ji how long do I stay on this and
then go to this right so what I did was
I just tested it out I tested out
certain temperatures and I wrote down I
did it about I think i did about eight
or nine times we were really sick and
pork belly after that mantra okay um and
after a while i settled on an approach
which is not yet this is perfect okay
you start off a 230 degrees you do it
for about 18 minutes and then you bring
it down to about 165 okay and then you
go depending on weight you do it anyway
so you go on a run so a question
yeah okay good question in terms of
optimizing there is sort of an
assumption that either there is a set of
there's a range of multiple solutions
which are valid for testing and you test
all of them you test as many as you can
okay in the case where it's like I've
got an infinite set right they would
give they would restrict it to what we
call the domain right so this is so like
math language right so if you've got
everything obviously you can't test
every single one there's a different set
right so you'd restrict it in some kind
of band and you you sort of be able to
know because after you start going in
this particular direction your answers
start to get worse at achieving your
outcomes lot better okay um but in truly
divergent situations you know this
you've raised the problem because how do
I test all them I can't right so that's
why this is not the only strategy that's
used yeah so bring it down to a little
more decision support system you sort of
situation rather than things which are
quite you know everyday life okay let's
think about investment when you're
dealing with money say you've got a
whole bunch of savings okay let's say
you've got ten thousand dollars in
savings okay how much do you put in to
say if you have two choices okay you
might be able to put it into a
short-term account one way you can draw
out money at any time okay but it only
earns such as you know an amount of
interest or you can put it in and lock
it in somewhere for same 12 months or 24
months all right for a long period time
and as a reward for that don't give you
higher interest okay now you've got lots
of questions to ask right like how much
what proportion should I have because
obviously you don't put all in there in
case there's an emergency all right but
is probably like pointless to keep all
of it here because you don't need all of
it at any given time four to ten
thousand dollars you generally don't
need to draw in that Adam moment's
notice okay so the question of how much
should I put in each it's like well
that's tricky okay so you might use
optimization to
run through a bunch of different
situations okay maybe one thousand nine
thousand or two thousand eight thousand
or 37 you get the idea okay and see what
kinds of results that would lead to for
how much money you would earn off your
interest after a certain amount of time
and then you would pick the solution you
think is the best ok so it's
optimization